a very interesting exchange took place
this weekend
carried out on the the internet so it's
part of the techno sphere and it has to
do
explicitly with the role of opinion and
a number of other topics
in the technosphere in the way in which
we live
and i think it's kind of interesting
that it took place between two what we
would call opinion
forums one of them is a magazine called
n plus one and the the editors published
a piece called against the rage machine
and then the hana rent center
with their their
weekend newsletter called the more mundi
which i'm a reader of
published a piece which was called
why must we care and why must we care
was was a
critical send up
and i think in some respects um off-base
set of of uh
attacks or criticisms or however you
want to put it of the the n plus one
article
so what i want to do with with this
is first of all
um
talk about what's actually in these
these pieces what the arguments are what
the positions are that people are saying
and then i want to explore some of the
important issues that are going on that
i think they
they touched on
they
could have gone a lot further with but
actually dropped the ball on
and i want to look at the criticism that
roger berkowitz is making of
the n plus one
editors in his piece why i think that
he's somewhat off base and i think that
marshalling hannah rent actually
overlooks some some important aspects of
her thought
and then i want to
talk about
some of the bigger issues
that that whether you read these these
these pieces or not and i think that
everybody should read these pieces so
i'm linking to them here
whether you read them or not
they they're really great things to
think about having to do with where we
put our attention and how we feel about
that
in terms of consumers and also content
producers in in the techno technosphere
in in the internet and how it's
inter-penetrated
all these different aspects of our our
life that existed before the internet
but have taken on
new
weight new function in many cases have
have come to the fore for people in ways
that that previously weren't possible
for them so first let me actually run
through the the
piece against the rage machine and i
think that the the title
is actually a misnomer as i read through
it i i'm i'm
not going to
comment on it i'm just going to try to
bring out the most salient points i'm
not going to read all of it but i'll put
you know quite a bit of it out there
so it begins a strange mania governs the
people of our great nation a mania that
these days results in many individual
and collective miseries this is the love
of opinion of free speech a furious
mania for free spoken opinion it
exhausts us we are aware that to say so
freely our opinion makes us hypocrites
we are also aware that america's hatred
of hypocrisy is one of the few passions
to rival its love of free speech as if
the ideal citizen must see something say
something and it must be the same thing
all the time but we'll be hypocrites
because we're tired and we eventually
want to stop talking that's the very
first paragraph
um and then they they give some examples
having to do with the the syrian crisis
and what was going on in popular culture
they talk about the
uh
uh the the the uh
i'm 124
sandwiches away from an engagement ring
piece that came out and you know how
people
oriented themselves around that
and
i'm going to skip over all those
examples because you can read them for
yourself so the right to have a feeling
and say it the right to care the right
to comment and have your voice heard
you'd think this is the only right we
have
and they they advocate what they call a
right to indifference as well as opinion
and here's part of their their critical
analysis to say i deserve to be heard
today is a vexed proposition right and
left tech corporations beg you to say
your peace for the sake of content
generation free from free publicity hype
and ad sales america's speech is so free
it pays not just just not you even when
we don't opine just clicking around
we're like silly on the tracheal lining
of some gross beast and our small work
of enthusiasm like pat liking or passing
along or reiterating or linking is like
the wriggle of a hair pushing the story
down the throat of the culture filling
its lungs so that it may breathe we may
accept this we can accept this we are a
hair and we quite we would quietly
concede our five dollar annual value to
facebook and twitter if only they
stopped asking us what's on our minds if
only they left us alone
instead they enjoined us to care and
about so many things why
our attention is both finite and worth
something we should not spend it on the
vmas and it goes through a whole bunch
of other things and then they talk about
rage and the function of
anger in this this economy of attention
they say
yet these things enrage us we can't live
this way we were so mad staring at our
phone reading opinions we just walked
into a planter
and they go over a bunch of examples
and then they say it's not just us the
ragers in our feeds or otherwise
reasonable friends and comrades how do
they have this energy this time for
these unsolicited opinions they keep
finding things to be mad about
uh and again i'm not going to go through
all the examples
then they say we're familiar with the
engines of the rage machine click bait
in publications fear-mongering and
official political statements the
scandalous and mainstream performance
the problematic in academia and art
these are theory genres inexhaustible
genres genres that will always drum up
attention it is understood that a
reader's emotional investment in any of
these will produce a contribution in
quotes
which circulates the subject of
conversation and keeps it and its
platform relevant and therefore alive
under these conditions caring becomes a
liability we pity the suckers who fall
for the rager of the weak those mad for
a day people who can't see how much of
the latest outburst is news and quotes
but not news
then they they look at another kind of
rage a bit one that's a bit more
personal one they're willing to take
responsibility for they say we are also
at other times the minds who suffer
worse the people whose passions and
priorities as real and relevant without
the newspaper become fodder for the rage
machine whenever there's a slow day at
buzzfeed we've been caring about this
stuff for years we think where were the
angry people then and then reflectively
they say of course this is the stupidest
rage of all it's embarrassing and
regressive like like teenage
possessiveness as if our favorite group
just got picked up by a major label
and then they go on and they they talk
about
they're actually getting away from the
topic of rage here and they're talking
about something that they don't realize
is actually more
uh pervasive always pick sides team
aniston the internet demands that even
if it's only half thoughts it wants
thoughts like this just this or this is
everything
this is not a sentence nor is best dot
thing dot ever
nor
exclamation points
but worse than in quit enthusiasm is the
think piece at the other end of the
spectrum a form of recreational
sophistry usually in the service of some
[ __ ] was proust a urologist girls
not bloomberg evicted zuccotti park does
breathing make you smarter and you can
you know you just run through all these
sort of listicles that people have and
uh you know you realize there's a ton of
that sort of content out there
so here's their their their key point we
assert our right to not care about stuff
to not say anything to opt out of debate
over things that are silly and also
things that are serious because why
pretend to have a strong opinion when we
do not
why are we being asked to participate in
some imaginary game of risk where we
have to take a side
and they go down and say
we ought to be selective about who
deserves our good faith some people do
get out to solve problems others pick
fight for the spectacle knowing we'll
stick around to watch in the meantime
they sell us refreshments as we loiter
on the sideline waiting to see which
troll will out troll his troll
then they go on and they talk about an
example of a friend from los angeles
that i'm going to skip over and they
they have this this uh this paragraph
that um roger berkowitz from the hana
rent center is going to pick up on and
say here's where they're really showing
their
their cards and going wrong
truth is not an imperative but something
that must be discovered
unlike liquid opinion truth does not
always circulate it is that which you
experience deeply and cannot forget the
right to care is the right to sit still
to not talk to be subject to unclarity
and allow knowledge to come unbidden to
you
to be in a constant state of rage by
contrast
is only
the other side of piety and
pseudoscience the kind of belief that
forms a quick chorus it cannot be
disproved
so that is the set of ideas somewhat
loosely connected uh as we're going to
see
in the the piece the the rage machine
in n plus one
and the hana rent uh
a more monday vlog this this sunday head
is one of the pieces that they had why
must we care
um
it starts out and there's a lot of
excerpts from the n plus one article
that i'm not going to you know read
through
is there such a thing as too much free
speech the editors at n plus one think
so they posted an editorial this week
lamenting the overabundance of speaking
that has swept over our nation like a
plague
the n plus one editors feel besieged and
we all we can all sympathize with their
predicament too many people are writing
blogs too many voices are tweeting too
many friends are pontificating about
something on facebook then there are the
trolls it's hard not to sympathize with
our friends at n plus one why do we have
to listen to all these folks shouldn't
all these folks just stop and read n
plus one instead and there it starts to
get a little snarky and there's
discussions about the hypocritical that
i'm going to skip over
and just mention a bit later
because they say beyond the hypocrisy n
plus one has a point the internet has
unleashed packs upon packs of angry
often rabid dogs these haters attack
anything and everything including each
other hate and rage are everywhere
they say wouldn't it be nice if public
if if public discourse were civil and
loving i too would prefer a rational
discussion about the boycott diversity
and sanction movement i would be
thrilled that the tea party and occupy
wall street could join forces to fight
political corruption and the over
bureaucratic bureaucratization of
government that disempowers individuals
and of course i would love it if those
who religiously attack conor rent for
her opinion that adolf
eichmann was a superficial and banal man
responsible for unspeakable evils could
find common cause with find her
provocative moving and meaningful
and then he goes on he says of course it
is exhausting dealing with those with
whom we don't see eye to eye and there's
always the impulse to simply say enough
i don't want to hear your opinions
anymore this is precisely what n plus
one is saying we don't care
now here's where the the fundamental
criticize criticism lies
underlying n plus one's ironic distance
from the area the arena of opinions and
discord is a basic anti-political
fantasy that opinion is a waste of time
if it is not destructive wouldn't it be
better to skip the opinions and the
battles and disagreements and just cut
straight to the truth
then he says what n plus one embraces is
truth over opinion and escapism over
engagement with others what they forget
however is that there are two
fundamentally opposed roots to truth in
one the truth seeker turns away from the
world of opinion the world in which we
live is a world of shadows and
deceptions truth won't be found in the
marketplace of ideas but on the
mountaintop and the blinding light of
the sun like plato's philosopher's king
we must climb out of the cave and ascend
to the heights alone turn to the heavens
and the eternal truths that surf upon
the sun rays we open ourselves to the
experience of truth a second view of
truth is more mundane the truth seeker
stays firmly planted in the world of
opinion and deception truth is a battle
and it is fought with the weapons of
words persuasion and rhetoric replace
the light of the sun the winner gains
not insight but power truth doesn't
emerge from an experience truth is the
settled sentiment of the most persuasive
opinion
and then he he grants that both of these
are are you know needed for different
kinds of things
and the philosopher needs the on the
mountain top kind of truth sort of
theologians but politicians like he says
cannot concern themselves with absolute
truths they must embrace the life of the
citizen and the currency of opinion
rather than the truths of the
philosopher in politics no opinion is
self-evident as a rent understood in
matters of opinion he's quoting here
rent uh but but not in matters of
philosophical truth our thinking is
discursive running as it were from place
to place from one part of the world to
another through all kinds of conflicting
views until it finally ascends from
these particularities to some impartial
generality
so then what he says is what a rent
understands
about political truths is that truths do
indeed circulate in messy and often
uncomfortable ways that the n plus one
editorial board wishes to avoid
political thought around argues is
representative by that she means it must
sample as many different viewpoints and
opinions as possible form i form an
opinion by considering a given issue
from different viewpoints
by making present to my mind the
standpoints of those who are absent that
is i represent them
it is in hearing imagining and
representing opposing and discordant
views that one comes to test out his or
her own views
it is not a matter of empathy of feeling
like someone else it's rather an
imaginative experiment in which i test
my views against all comers
in this way the enlarged mentality of
imaginative thinking is the prerequisite
for judgment
um
it goes on and it says
in the internet and age we are bombarded
with such a diversity of angry and
insulting and stupid and offensive
viewpoints it is only natural it is it
is only natural to alternate between the
urge to respond violently in the urge to
withdraw
political thinking requires that we
resist both the desire to fight opinions
with violence and the desire to flee
from opinions altogether instead we we
need to learn to think in and with
others whose opinions we often hate
we must find in the melee of divergent
and offending opinions the joy that
exists in the experience of human
plurality we don't need to love or agree
with those we find offensive but so long
as they are talking instead of fighting
we should respect them and listen to
them indeed we should care about them
and their beliefs
this is why the
n plus one manifesto for not caring is
your weekend read
so
two very interesting pieces uh one a
critique of the other one
a critique that isn't in many respects
actually off base and contains some some
glaring
uh
what do we want to call them
inconsistencies uh performative
contradictions uh oversights of of its
own a little bit of its own uh
rhetoric uh in the in the bad sense
um
one of the things that i i'd like to
point out right off the bat is there's
some discussion in there about hypocrisy
and for me that's that's a blind alley
or a red herring it contributes nothing
to the discussion so i want to
completely set it aside
if other people want to to take that up
they're perfectly free to
but i i don't see it as as uh relevant
to
all the great stuff that's that's being
discussed here about the ways in which
internet culture
has
changed the the landscape of
opinion and opinion formation and how we
ought to think about these sorts of
things
so
what's actually
the the guiding
idea behind the n plus one if we want to
call it a manifesto
well we're asking several different
questions there we might be saying
what's their their programmatic response
what is their diagnosis
of the situation what is their analysis
of the causes that lead to the symptoms
of the situation
we want to be careful with each each of
these to actually get it right
what their what they're saying and and
look at what they are
saying without realizing it and then uh
missing out on
so
i think that
one basic starting point that we can all
agree on is both of these pieces
are actually doing a great job in
acknowledging just how
messy and frustrating and demanding the
life of of anybody who aims to be
sort of an engaged not only consumer but
participant in discussions about things
that matter on the internet
how how difficult that can be how
demanding how exhausting
and i think that both of them do a
pretty good job in pointing out certain
certain aspects or certain types
of situations in which this occurs you
know the facebook friends who post
endlessly about their political views or
about condemning this or you know this
this aspect of culture that has to
change and they do this from right and
from left just about equally
what goes on is they say things and then
other people respond to them and and
usually
discussions on facebook and on google
plus and on
linkedin even and on twitter tend not to
be very enlightening or enlightened in
the sense that there's an actual
exchange of viewpoints where people are
really considering other people's views
instead what goes on is what they call
siloing
either you have like a free-for-all and
everybody's shouting at each other or
everybody agrees and obama is you know
the messiah or obama is the antichrist
just to pick one one thing or you know
the republicans are horrible because
they're doing this or the republicans
are are you know great because they're
doing that and we can go on and on with
example after example miley cyrus was
courageous miley cyrus is you know
merely you know pandering to sell
records
you can come up with example after
example of things that people will weigh
in on
and
where the two pieces diverged with
respect to that is that the n plus one
piece
is very much focused in its analysis
in not just talking about the fact that
this goes on and that we're bombarded
by by people saying things that are
usually
controversial and when we examine them
usually have a lot of holes in them and
would require a lot of additional
support to be even plausible
we're also being invited or not even
really invited we're being pressured to
ourselves
engage in that sort of thing
and to do so in a way that is rather
restrictive
but now
um
over simplifying something that gets
away from what it means to be
a
engaged complex
developing
human being
we're being invited to become something
like
pure consumers who are at the same time
also
reproducers and reproducers
in in not any sort of creative poetic
sense but reproducers merely in a kind
of
generate the same product again but with
a couple different tweaks from a
slightly different angle
that's what's missing in the a more
mundi analysis of the n plus one
discussion
now i think that the the n plus one
discussion is is uh missing a few things
but i i to remain on this point and sort
of draw draw out what exactly they're
complaining about
with respect to this particular aspect
so
let's go back to this line the right to
have a feeling and say it the right to
care the right to comment and have your
voice heard
it's very interesting that they put this
in terms of rights
because oftentimes
we look at rights as being correlative
to duties but this is the way that we
look at rights and duties i have a right
therefore you have a corresponding duty
so if i have a right to property you
have a duty to respect my property and
not you know destroy it not steal it etc
etc right if i have a right to life you
have a duty not to kill me and not to
allow me to be killed through your own
inaction
what's going on here is something very
different something that that's similar
to what um
you know a lot of theorists the one who
comes to mind for me is actually michel
foucault
um
because he talks about this but also
jacques lacan too you know this this
imperative uh to
to engage in in certain things i have a
right to speak therefore i must speak
therefore i'm doing wrong if i don't
speak i have a right to have an opinion
so therefore i must express an opinion
and if the only range of opinions that
are easily available to me are this
narrowly restricted
uh you know panoply that are that are
given to me uh by other people and i'm
expected to do it on the spot right away
this doesn't feel like a right anymore
does it it starts to feel very
confining
and there's this this strange paradox
here that all this freedom brings about
within a social setting
especially the social setting of uh
engaged social networking and news
reporting and opinion reporting
it brings about a whole you know set of
feelings particularly the more
conscientious a person is i should i
should care about this i should have a
feeling about this i should have an
opinion about this my opinion should
actually be researched
and thought out not just be a knee-jerk
reflex reaction
there's something like an imperative
there that's being placed upon us
through this entire network and
unfortunately it's an imperative usually
to to produce things that will neatly
fit into to structures into
classifications right left you know blue
red
or into narratives classic narratives or
new narratives
and we're being asked to fit our our our
opinions
uh which means not just our our you know
feeling our our actual statements but
also the feelings driving them into this
this matrix which like i said is very
often quite restrictive
and i think that they're dead right
about that you know um
and i think that one of the things that
they they rightly focus on
is this this passage right and left tech
corporations beg you to say your piece
for the sake of content generation free
from publicity hype and ad sales
this is to the benefit
of
the ones who own run
and disseminate the networks
the ones who
engage in in this sort of thing
and make money off of it
clicks
equal eyeballs equal ad revenue
so
i should remember too that for all of
these news outlets ad revenue really is
one of the major things that keeps them
afloat
um
and pays the salaries of those who are
who are involved in it so even like they
say even acts that don't seem to be
opinion expressive in the sense of like
actually writing out a status in
facebook just clicking on something
already feeds into this entire process
where we're
on you know in a certain respect invited
to have opinions and on the other
you know
side of it expected demanded to to say
something to feel something to think
something whatever it may happen to be
you aren't allowed to not express
yourself
even if there's a button that says you
know no opinion
or i don't want to say
that's even within a certain range
and i think that
that's one of the central
aspects of this this entire piece
that
the the criticism by
you know a more mundi
um
saying that
the editors at n plus one think there's
too much free speech they lamented the
over abundance of speaking it makes it
sound as as if the n plus one people are
complaining that there's too many other
people talking when what they're really
talking about
is
the fact that each one of us is called
upon to be a participant
in this and that it doesn't
do so in a way
that would in many cases really allow us
to to properly form
any sort of opinion that would be
well informed that would be cogent
and
the the the
hana rent piece is going to talk about
you know that aspect in terms of well if
we if we want to
make a good opinion for ourselves we
actually have to take in other people's
views
but what they've forgotten from the very
beginning is is the complaint here was
not just that there's too many people
talking it's that i'm expected
to
engage in this process of sort of
putting my own views out there
and i'm supposed to do so in a very
stereotyped way much of the time so
that's one key aspect of this
that i think is important to to think
more about
this imperative to not only consume but
to produce and thereby to reproduce
a second key aspect of this this entire
discussion that i think
gets left out a bit
in
it gets underplayed a bit in in the n
plus one piece
even though it's really the most central
point and it's totally ignored
in the more mundi piece
is
the issue of time and attention
they
you know
they're saying
that um
here it is our attention is both finite
and worth something we should not spend
it and then they give some examples of
unworthy
things that we should devote them to you
know later on they talk about we ought
to be selective about who deserves our
good faith
and
this is a place where we really have to
um
stop and think we have to devote some
time ironically to understanding the
importance of time
we don't have the time
to listen to everybody's opinions
we we don't owe everybody
the opportunity to engage with us in
part because
you know given the plethora of available
interlocutors in the communications
communicative situation that we inhabit
now even just on facebook or twitter not
to mention if you're actually actively
engaging other people
given the the sheer number of
interlocutors you cannot
engage with all of them
to the same degree as a matter of fact
you have to
silence effectively for yourself some
voices and say i'm not going to listen
to this one i'm not going to listen to
this one i've i you know after the first
sentence into this i know this guy's
schtick and i i'm just not going to
devote the time
and
berkowitz and his criticism of the n
plus one people i think that's something
he's he's leaving out
he's he's spelling out this this great
um
sort of you know classic conception of
uh you really figure out what your own
opinions are and who you are in
engagement with other people and taking
their opinion seriously but he leaves
out the fact that that takes time and
time is a
uh
it's a it's a it's a valuable resource
that you can't get from other places you
can't actually
take in everybody's opinions you have to
be selective to some degree about who
you're going to listen to and the more
that and you also have to be you know
just in how you apportion the time that
you have the precious time that you have
if you're going to engage with this
person and spend an hour with them
that's an hour that you can't spend
looking at what other people are saying
or even going back and forth with them
in a comment section or in an email
exchange or a facebook exchange
you're always
you know going to have to
make choices about where to devote your
time
who to dedicate your time to and i think
that
we really ought to think about this in
terms of deserving
what opinions am i going to learn from
now this you know i can be wrong about
that i could i could actually write
things off and then later on find out
that i shouldn't have written it off
because i actually do devote some time
to it but i think that the n plus one
editors are right in in standing up for
um the fact that we
shouldn't feel guilty
about saying no
i'm not going to to hear this this one
out
i am not going to read you know past the
first paragraph on this one
um
this could be done in a you know in the
wrong ways granted
but i think for those who are actually
conscientiously seeking out other
people's opinions in general it does
make sense to say they can become over
taxed they can give too much of their
time and attention and i i think that
when we're asked to
give our own views on things over and
over and over again
maybe uh we actually ought to think of
who does deserve to hear from me you
know i'll give you some examples from my
own um
work in life
i get solicited you know for um
what do you think about this what do you
think about that in in consumer ways all
the time for products that i use i don't
give them any information because in my
view if they want information from me
they can actually
first of all pay me for it and they're
not usually offering to pay me anything
and second they can ask me in a more
personal way i don't want some mass
email from hotels.com saying what did
you think about this place if the place
is particularly egregiously bad i may
write something about it if it's really
if i had really great service i may
write something about it but i don't
view it as
incumbent upon me to share with
everybody else
my own experiences and views in part
because i don't have the time if i did
actually have 48 hours a day or 72 hours
a day
maybe i'd see it differently but i only
get the same 24 that i used to get when
i was 18 years old and thought i had all
the time in the world and i'm going
gonna get the same 24 when i'm 80 and
you know counting down the the how much
time i've got and i get the same 24 as
anybody else anywhere else in the
history of the world
there's no way to get more time
for any one given person you can try to
do time management you can try to
maximize your effectiveness in the use
of it but that's there you hit a law of
diminishing returns with that sort of
thing and when it comes to our
attentional economy our attentional
resource
our ability to actually
dig into something and say i think i i
understand what you're saying and here's
where i agree with you and here's where
i differ from you doing that kind of
intellectual work and it is work
requires time
it requires a resource
and i i think that
we don't have to give it to everybody i
don't respond to every single facebook
or not facebook but um
youtube comment that i get these days i
still respond to most of them but i i
you know i i'm selective about which
ones i will engage with more and which
ones i will engage with less there are
some comments that are bone-headed and
actually don't really deserve a response
people who ask about you know whether i
have
videos on this topic or that topic and
have never you know done the few clicks
that it would take to actually look at
the playlist you know do you have any
videos about existentialism well yeah of
course i do i've got you know
a whole playlist about it and all it
would take is a couple clicks and you'd
be able to answer that i don't feel that
i actually am on call
to answer every single question i i have
to choose which ones i'm going to give
more attention to and which ones i'm
going to say
i'm not going to i'm not going to engage
with that one so people want to have
arguments and debates i don't spend a
lot of time
on a lot of arguments and debates
because
if i can tell that it's not going to be
productive
you know i i need to spend my time doing
other things like for example shooting
videos like reading things and thinking
about them um like choosing which things
i'm going to
you know ruminate upon and and uh talk
about
so i think that the n plus one people
actually
are on to something that that's that's
being missed in the the more mundy um
thing i would actually go so far to turn
the the you know accusation of living
out a kind of fantasy onto berkowitz and
say
he's living out this eminently political
fantasy about
uh
this you know opportunity for endless
speech with others
because you know portraying
the process of forming one's own
opinions
as if one possessed almost you know
inexhaustible leisure to to engage with
this and engage with this and engage
with this which is what he seems to
lapse into towards the end
that to me seems to be a kind of fantasy
which is on the same level as the
fantasy about about truth that he's
accusing
um the n plus one editor editors of
lapsing into
um
a third thing that i'd like to talk
about
is
the fact that this really is not about
rage
or not only about rage
that's what the n plus one people
focused in on and they put it in their
title you know the rage machine
berkowitz is actually on to the right
thing by by asking the question why
should we care
because rage or anger is only one of the
modalities in which we're being invited
to to care about things i would say that
another
whole set are there and being discussed
in the n plus one article and among
those they include
the drive of curiosity
and to roll all these into rages
actually to oversimplify a bit and to
muddy the analysis of of things so i
mean there's some great discussions
about the the the you know the factor of
rage and you know i like this this one
in particular where they cop to saying
um yeah we're like these kids who
uh you know are possessive as if our
favorite group just got picked up by a
major label i was mad about this before
you know who the hell are you people do
not get mad about it uh and you know
really one ought to be saying oh great
other people have finally caught on that
this thing that i find intolerable and
you know want to have changed actually
they actually see it that way
why don't we
because on a certain level we feel like
they're the johnny come lately's they're
the dilettantes they're the ones who
don't really understand what it is that
they're they're criticizing and we do
we've put in the time we're the ones who
kind of deserve to be out there in the
forefront you know holding up the sign
and getting on the
tv screen
there's an element of
narcissism
you know poorly managed emotions there
but i think there's also an element
of realizing
that
yes the others that are johnny come
lately perhaps they're not as committed
about this and perhaps the the reasons
they have for expressing the opinions or
having the feelings that they do are not
as well
formed not as well thought out
not as fully developed
and i think they could go for the other
things
that they're they're talking about as
well
you know this passage where they say
always pick sides you know and then they
talk about um
this the word this is not a sentence nor
is best thing ever
these best thing ever things and i would
say that a lot of you know what we
nowadays label as porn that's not
actually porn like food porn or
uh you know
location porn or
you know
we could really call anything we want
you know football porn during the super
bowl everybody getting hyped up about
stuff
that's not appealing to rage that's not
appealing to that emotion of anger
that's appealing to other emotions
trying to get us to be always you know
like oh yeah i gotta read this article i
gotta have something to say about this
um you know here's some examples
that are some of these are made up but
some of these weren't what breaking bad
teaches us about building brands what
breaking bad teaches us about the war on
drugs what breaking bad teaches us about
toxic relationships
um
these are mostly bs
and you know what what's actually true
in them is usually common sense or you
can find it somewhere else it has
nothing to do with breaking bad but
somebody's getting paid to to produce
these things or some somebody's you know
producing these
because they're trying to like break in
or you know they get a kick out of doing
this sort of thing
none of this makes us any more
intelligent or better informed about
things in any substantive meaningful way
and yet why do we put our eyeballs on it
and why do we scroll down with the mouse
because we're curious
because we want to know
um
you know like like he says in here the
editor he says it makes you appreciate
the listicles honest hypo ambition it's
the true slacker of internet forms
so when when they say we assert our
right to not care about stuff to not say
anything to opt out of debate over
things that are silly and also things
that are serious it's not just to opt
out of debate over
things that people are angry about
it's about things that people are hyped
about
things that people are you know saying
you gotta see this you gotta see this
video you gotta you know read this this
list it's gonna change your life a lot
of the the motivational speaker
self-help you know transform your
business transform your life
uh sort of article genre would fit in
there as well i don't think that you're
actually under an obligation to
read that stuff or even to
pay any attention to it at all
i agree with the people in n plus one
about that there's there is too much of
that stuff out there and by wanting us
to share it by wanting us to comment on
it um we're being done a kind of
disservice
and i think that that's more in some
respects that's more insidious than this
endless pool of anger and rage that gets
drawn upon
i think that there we could say that
there's other things going on
as well
you know people when pinterest first
came out
found themself losing not just hours but
days
going through and endlessly categorizing
pins
why
it's the same sort of imperative that's
going on with this add to things add
content
say your piece
and it's almost always being done in
very narrow
very
superficial
not a lot of opportunity for putting
your own self in there in any sort of
creative way
modes
that's what they're complaining about
i think that there's an interesting
discussion and this is the fourth point
i want to make about truth here and i
think that the n plus one people are
on to something and also wrong and i
think that uh amor mundi is also being
tendentious here and just to a certain
extent
um
using a rent
but also kind of misusing
her thought at the same time
so let's actually look at what what you
know the the criticism is
uh and we'll go back to well let's look
at the n plus one thing truth is not an
imperative but something that must be
discovered unlike liquid opinion truth
does not always circulate i think that's
right
truth
in in the sense of you know getting at
the real
story which tends to be messy which
tends to be multifaceted which actually
reflects the realities that we're
talking about yes it doesn't circulate
as well as the the easy tiny content
that can be shared
sent out there you know in a press
release you know in a blast and that
people can you know give a thumbs up to
right away or you know thumbs up thumbs
down like on youtube
it
there's there's something to that
um
it is that what you must this is that
what you experience deeply and cannot
forget
they're
okay
truth is not always something you
experience
it may be for for some people but i
think that's a kind of consumeristic
uh view on on truth that would benefit
by reading some of the classic
discussions of truth in aristotle and in
augustine and anselm and seeing that
there's more to truth and william james
too more to truth than just you know
what i experience deeply and cannot
forget
um but then they say the right not to
care is the right to sit still not to
not talk to be subject to unclarity and
to allow knowledge to come unbidden to
you
and i would say
that you know there's some good stuff in
there and then some bad stuff knowledge
to come unbidden to you uh berkowitz is
right to zero in on that and say yeah
this is just this sort of notion that if
you just quiet and still
the truth will reveal itself to you and
that you know
i don't know many philosophers who
actually believe that um plato sure as
hell didn't
uh even though you know berkowitz talks
about plato there um
and you know and the process of getting
yourself out of the cave is not this you
know
mindfulness meditation we're just gonna
like be still and hear what's what's
being said by the universe no it's an
assist it's hard work
to get to truth
at least for plato for aristotle and
augustine and people like that
so we shouldn't trivialize it
but then you know
what else is is actually right in there
to to to say that
um
the right not to care is the right to
sit still to not talk to be subject to
unclarity
what we're talking about there is
leisure
it requires a certain amount of
free time
that perhaps you've carved out and
notice you you can only carve out time
by depriving other stuff of time
so you carve that time out
so you can actually
think about things in in medieval times
they call this ruminatio ruminating upon
things and it wasn't just a passive
kind of well i'm gonna let the truth
come to me
nonsense that's you know being advocated
by n plus one it was an active process
of revolving things in your mind of
thinking them through of looking at
their their different sides and their
multifacetes you know facetiousness or
multifacetedness
but they are into the the you know the
right track and saying you need some
actual leisure some time that's not
being devoted to talk talk talk you know
repeating things replicating the memes
that are out there
in order to make that happen
now
the the criticism that's being made here
is that n plus one is is actually
engaging in ironic distance from the
arena of opinions and discord uh i'm not
sure that they're actually doing that if
it is just merely ironic in the hipster
sense of ironic um then it's valid
criticism but if they're saying that we
actually need some time and leisure to
be able to think things through
uh then the criticism's off base
he also calls it a basic anti-political
fantasy that opinion is a waste of time
if it's not destructive again i don't
see n plus one actually saying that
about all opinion
um
wouldn't it be better just to skip the
opinions and the battles and
disagreements and just cut straight to
the truth and then then he he produces n
plus ones uh you know discussion about
truth which falls into that but i don't
think is really representative of their
position
then he goes and he says when what n
plus one embraces is truth over opinion
and escapism against engagement with
others and what they're forgetting is
that there's two fundamentally opposed
roots to truth
in one the truth seeker is turning away
from the world of opinion and the the
example that's used here is you know
plato's philosopher king who climbs out
of the cave in a sense of the heights
one of the things that's totally left
out of that he doesn't climb out of the
cave he's actually dragged out of the
cave by other people who've been up
there it takes him a long time to adjust
but you know let's go along with this
total caricature of play-doh for the for
the time being and see what's being said
you know the notion is you got to get
away from everybody else and then the
truth will impress itself on you that's
more that's more thoreau than plato but
a okay
second view of truth the truth seeker
stays firmly planted in the world of
opinion and deception truth is a battle
and is fought with the weapons of words
persuasion and rhetoric replace the
light of the sun the winner gains not
insight but power
truth doesn't emerge from experience
truth is a settled sentiment of the most
persuasive opinion
well
yes and no
often times the
the settled sentiment of the most
persuasive opinion doesn't get power
and we know that's the case
there's oftentimes many different
you know
settled sentiments of the most
persuasive
but not the one that actually has the
guns
or the the economic power
or
you know other forms of cultural power
so that's kind of a fantasy right there
that's being expressed um
the truth keeper stays firmly planted in
the world truth is a battle is fought
with the weapons of words well what we
call not just persuasion and rhetoric
but also dialectic isn't it and who
engaged in dialectic
socrates
plato
aristotle augustine
these guys weren't just retiring up to
the mountainside and uh you know waiting
for the truth to come to them
they were actually taking in everybody
else's opinions at least some of them
and seeing whether they actually merited
being being thought about
and so i think that there's you know
it's one thing to accuse the n plus one
writers of engaging in kind of an
escapist fantasy i think this is also an
escapist fantasy too because it's it's
clearly a you know a
total
you know misrepresentation
of the way most people actually
including philosophers view truth
um
and he's harnessing a rent here and in
this you know this famous discussion of
a rant that that's distinguishing
between you know philosophical approach
to truth and and politics
um
and he says what iran understands about
political truth is that truths do indeed
circulate in a messy and often
uncomfortable way that the n plus one
editorial board wishes to avoid
i think that they're saying
what's important let's let's get away
from the word truth because they they
did step in it by you know coming up
with this this discussion of truth that
was it was kind of off base uh and left
them subject to that critique but let's
say what's actually important what's
actually worth engaging with
does indeed circulate in messy and often
uncomfortable ways but that doesn't mean
that we need to allow every messy and
uncomfortable way equal space or we're
doing the wrong thing we're depriving
ourselves
it goes on political thought is
representative by this means it must
sample as many different viewpoints and
opinions as possible i form an opinion
by considering a given issue from
different viewpoints by making present
to my mind the standpoints of those who
are absent that is i represent them that
by the way is what we call dialectic
that's classical dialectic
and
what the m plus one people are
criticizing in part is
what's going on in the internet in the
in the technosphere that's affected our
discourse so that it's actually not
sampling as many different viewpoints
and opinions as possible when you're
being asked to you know click a or b or
c
and these are all sort of like written
out ahead of time
that's not a question that's not a case
of sampling as many diverse opinions and
viewpoints as possible
and you know
you're not actually just sampling them
you actually want to think through them
you want to see you want to sift them
you want to see whether there's anything
there you don't actually have to look at
everything to know that there's no wheat
there it's all just chaff
and you're not that's not incumbent upon
you
this sampling itself i think is subject
to corruption to degeneration and that's
what happens
in a lot of this this you know are you
on this side or this side that's what
the n plus one people are talking about
berkowitz is off base
in how he's using a rent here to
criticize them he's criticizing uh
somebody he's criticizing a strong man
effectively he's right in his criticism
but that's not what the n plus one
people are actually
saying and what he's overlooking is that
in order to actually
be able to sample as many different
viewpoints and opinions as possible then
to form an opinion by considering a
given issue from different viewpoints
you need leisure
and you also need a certain developed
capacity of judgment
that we call phronesis in ancient
philosophy you know practical wisdom
something else that rents spent a lot of
time thinking about and talking about
that's not something you can take for
granted in everybody that's not
something that you can take for granted
in every interlocutor
that's something that has to be
cultivated and the process of
cultivation is ongoing really never
finished for any of us
but that's something that would be
required in order to tell is this
[ __ ] is this stuff that i don't
actually need to watch or think about or
is this actually something that's worth
engaging with
you need some degree of phronesis to be
able to do that
not everybody has it
i would say if there's anything that's
incumbent about a person it's incumbent
to develop phronesis to develop you know
the capacity to make good judgments
about these sorts of things uh that's in
that's an important constituent of this
very process of
dialectically gathering and sifting
other people's opinions and if you don't
have that then you're just sort of
sampling in a superficial consumeristic
way a whole bunch of people's thoughts
about stuff
you may as well just be listening to
songs on itunes
and seeing whether you like the way the
sounds you know the way this the song
sounds and whether it sort of appeals to
you emotionally
um rather than actually you know
thinking about what you want to
integrate
to become part of your own perspective
so i think that's a you know very
important thing to think about when
we're talking about these views of truth
i think that the view of truth that's
that's being
uh articulated by the n plus one people
is unfortunate and and to some degree
mistaken i think that the view of truth
that's being critically articulated by
berkowitz in response to and as critique
of the n plus one thing is also uh to
some degree untrue misguided it's an
untrue view on truth itself
and to that degree it's going to be
somewhat unhelpful for us here i think
that what we need is something that's a
bit more sophisticated that actually
looks like the people who rent kept
going back to over and over again plato
aristotle augustine you know we could go
down the list of people who who would
have more to contribute here in their
views of truth
the last thing that i want to talk about
here
is
the move from what i'm going to call the
move from a dilemma to a trilemma at the
end
berkowitz is right to point out
that he says in the internet age we are
bombarded with such a diversity of angry
insulting and stupid and defensive
viewpoints and i would also add you know
predatory
um overly happy happy happy
uh curiosity provoking
hyped up viewpoints let's just make you
know the
you know broad swath
we're bombarded with that so that it's
only natural to alternate between the
urge to respond violently and the urge
to withdraw
now violently of course he doesn't mean
you know we punch out the screen or you
know find the guy who posted this thing
and then punch him out he means to you
know um get angry to say that's that's
no good or to withdraw you know i would
say that um there's also the the option
of saying yeah right on that's exactly
what i think and being a joiner
so we're already moving past a dilemma
but he's framing it as a dilemma and
then he says political thinking
requires that we both resist the desire
to fight opinions with violence that is
you know in the word of war
in the world of words i suppose violence
would be to get angry and say you're a
jerk
or to engage in all sorts of passive
aggressive behavior that goes on in
common sections as well
and the desire to flee from opinions
altogether the zoning it out i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna you know pay
attention to any of you
instead we need to learn to think in and
with others whose opinion we often hate
so he's he's saying you know here's the
dilemma i've actually got a third term
and i would say that's insufficient
so you know to go from a false dilemma
to a false trilemma
is not really
furthering the conversation i think
it's not just about learning to think in
and with others whose opinions we often
hate that's an integral component it's
also about making leisure for ourselves
to actually be able to consider opinions
which is going to require us to actually
exclude some of those opinions some of
which we may hate some of which we may
love
but not all of which we can afford to
listen to
we have to learn to cultivate judgment
and that's going to be an ongoing
process
judgment about
which
sources we're actually going to to pay
attention to and judgment also about am
i going to involve myself in this do i
actually have a dog in this fight or can
i stay on the sidelines and see how
things sort themselves out do i need to
actually respond to this am i the
spokesperson who has to be involved from
my point of view
not always
so he says
you know we don't need to love or agree
with those we find offensive and it's
the emphasis is always on those we find
offensive i think we should be as
circumspect about those that we have a
knee-jerk sort of reflex action
agreement with as about those who we we
have the opposite reaction to and we
need to
be
willing to say no i'm not going to read
you
or i'm going to put you in the file that
i'll get to if i ever have the time
later on
and so you know when it comes down to it
i'm actually coming down on the side of
the n plus one editors
against a a
a way of looking at things that i'm much
more attracted to i have to admit you
know it's not often that i want to cross
you know intellectual swords with the
moore mundi and the hana rent center
let alone roger berkowitz
but i think that he's actually wrong on
this and that the n plus one editors
despite where they're actually
um you know off on some things like
their understanding of truth and they're
attributing this primarily to rage
i think that they've actually
got the better take on on these things
what i'd like to see is sort of fusing
these together where it's not just like
taking in other people's views but
attention to the time that we have the
need for leisure the need to cultivate
phronesis
this is some pretty abstract stuff but i
think that this is very important in
terms of reflections on what i've been
calling the technosphere and i think
that these are these are pointing us
towards skills and dispositions that we
need to consciously develop in order not
just to be
stuck in the swamp you know swirled
around in the soup and to end up being
nodes in somebody's network
to be
uh i guess you could say the task and
this is a very aurentian thing to say
the task in in this technosphere is to
be as as fully human as we can and that
means not abandoning
um some of the things that we've
actually achieved continuing to learn
from the the great you know ancient
medieval modern thinkers on these things
and applying them to this this new
context so that's what i've tried to do
in this this video about this polemic
between these two very interesting
pieces that i highly recommend that you
read